when you live paycheck to paycheck you
feel trapped if I quit my job I'm not
going to make rent I'm going to lose my
house lose the house the amount of 25 to
30 year olds that should move back in
with their parents around the world is
staggeringly high if their kpi is
happiness one step backwards two steps
forward my advice to people that feel
stuck is you're stuck because you're
living within the means of your take
home and if you can go 20 to 50 percent
lower than that well then you've started
to create the room for you to be able to
get out all I've been pushing for 15
years is like in your 20s go for it
because this is the generation you can
live with four guys in a [__] studio
apartment and eat [__] McDonald's and
call it a day you start becoming 37 and
you have a child and like you're in a
different game but even for a 37 year
old that has a mortgage and if you live
more humble you can like create that
freedom Gary you don't get it I'm
[__] living Bare Bones I'm like do
you take Uber yeah every day I'm like
take the bus do you order food yes cook
at home you'll save a fortune you're
telling me you're miserable you're
telling me that you want to live your
dream you're not willing to take the bus
for your dream then you're full of [__]